jäger damit bist du doch der absolute
waren mit ladekabel und was geht ab und
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
ja ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut ich
hoffe das müsste jetzt auch gut wenn ein
bisschen christian krank heute ist nicht
so schlimm
das schaffen wir schon da stehen wir
drüber wir machen heute ein neues
anwachsen video normalerweise habe ich
die immer leide ich habe heute marie
wieder dabei nach langer zeit machen das
freut mich auf jeden fall sehr
und heute geht es um die teuersten
sneaker der welt bestellt auf wunsch
sollte ganz kurz bevor es weitergeht
dieses video wird unterstützt von film-
oder als youtuber wird man ja sehr oft
gefragt alex welches schnittprogramm
benutzt du und ich bin da eigentlich
noch nie so wirklich darauf eingegangen
deswegen kann ich euch heute wirklich
mal 1 empfehlen ich muss sagen ich bin
ja jetzt auch schon ziemlich lange auf
youtube dabei und habe schon das eine
oder andere schnittprogramm durch viele
davon sind sehr kompliziert viele von
euch stellen sich das sicherlich auch
immer als ziemlich kompliziert vorhanden
video zu schneiden für mode hingegen es
erstens kostenlos und zweitens ziemlich
einfach also wirklich extrem leichte
text sofort worum es geht und was du da
machen kannst wir haben hier effekte
transitions titels wir haben musik die
mitgeliefert wird nun copyright act
music also ihr könnt direkt musik und
euer video legen die ganz normale
hochladen auf youtube monetarisieren und
so weiter und irgendwelche gedanken zu
machen ich habe immer ganz kurz ein paar
tipps von mir zusammen geschnitten alles
mit viel moral effekte benutzt wenn sich
uns benutzt so sieht das aus und es hat
wirklich nicht lange dauert also checkt
es ab erster link in der video
beschreibung
[Musik]
ich habe vor einiger zeit vier exemplare
bestellt also es gibt ja dass nico auf
der welt die wurden für 20.000 50.000
dollar verkauft echt ja die habe ich
jetzt natürlich nicht getauft aber ich
habe die fakes sozusagen davon
aufgestellt weißt du ich würde sagen
leute ich zeige euch einmal ganz kurz am
pc was sich da alles gestellt hätte mir
auch mal mit zeige ich dir natürlich auf
und dann packen wir die auch direkt
schon aus und vergleichen die auf einer
mit den originalen also wie teuer die
originale sind ja natürlich ich meine
dann wäre ich jetzt um 100.000 euro
ärmer leute was geht ab wir haben
folgende sneaker bestellt einmal hier
den air jordan 12 flug game den hat
michael jordan mal getragen und dieser
schuh wurde dann für 42.000 dollar
verkauft deswegen habe ich denn bestellt
weil ich dachte wird so hoch gehandelt
aber dann kriegt man tatsächlich auch
günstiger also aber ich habe trotzdem
bestellt und ist ein sehr teurer schuh
keine frage dass er ist jetzt der
staffel
ich kann mir nicht sagen ich habe
eigentlich vier exemplare bestellt haben
insgesamt so 150 200 euro gekostet
allerdings ein exemplar ist bis heute
nicht erreicht und ich muss einfach
weiter
ich muss einfach weiter das video drehen
ich kann jetzt nicht noch länger warten
das hat sich ja schon wieder ein
bisschen verzögert das tut mir total
leid aber ich würde sagen gestartet
diesmal mit diesem mir du kannst dir
gerne auch machen solche dem messer
holen ja hier
nein damit man nicht wo ja vorsichtig
denn immer vom körper weg sehr gut aber
wenn ich in die schule schneiden die
sind teuer
die verkauft auf ebay als die originale
weißt du welche das sind ja keine ahnung
das ist sind die ich bleibe es euch hier
mal kurz ein
ich will jetzt ja auch nichts weiter
sagen weil die sneaker kenner wissen das
natürlich ich bin jetzt aber ziemlich
sicher das ist ja den nicht zu stellen
habe das ist der nike air jordan 12 flug
game wurde für 40.000 us dollar bereits
verkauft also der jetzt ganz formal auch
an die ganzen sneaker experten von euch
also seid doch nicht zu hart mit mir
wenn ihr euch aus können schreibt gern
mal in die büro schreibt immer gerne in
die kommentare ich denke kriegt ja was
ihr davon haltet
naja ok ist schon heftig aber ich muss
sagen an sich die finde ich nicht
schlecht ne also 40.000 dollar kann man
schon mal verlangen
ich habe mir für 21 euro glaub ich
gekauft und also sonst gute qualität
oder die helfer sind direkt das ist
neuer schule dafür nicht deutlich sein
ach so ja man sieht hier die sind nicht
perfekt verarbeitet was man selbst auch
den lehrern sei hier soll ein zeichen
sein dass john zeichen dass auch hier
die leute hier ist das bloggen zeichen
jetzt muss ich die natürlich auch
anziehen oder und einmal mit meinem
outfit danke dann fragt nicht danach
direkt wie faceman ich bin das gestellt
werden
hier ist so richtig dieses papier in
würde altern
die riechen streng riecht man sagen ich
habe dir in schuhgröße 43 bestellt
perfekt für mich
das wird den swag natürlich in der ja
sehr weit nach oben schrauben
was ich für mich produzieren
alle bis auf meine hose 100 euro für
20.000 40.000 dollar gekauft und
oberteil kostet 80 euro also gesamtpreis
könnt ihr euch hier ein
auf jeden fall ein stabiles outfit aber
wie tragen sich jetzt die schuhe
ach so also ich würde sagen die schuhe
fühlen sich an sich auf jeden fall
bequem an
hier oben könnte ich mir vorstellen dass
man sich da ein bisschen blasen läuft
selbst wenn es erstmal wieder in die
last an solchen instagram verlosen
wieder könnte ich einfach mehr machen
internorm alex wie werden die ihnen die
story gepostet und da könnt ihr einfach
auf die story an sondern werden die
verlust von werten nicht gerade hoch
gesundheit werte nicht diese nike air
jordan 2 flog das ist ein bisschen neben
der rolle heute also mit das soll ganz
klar davon seien ja ja ich bin so ein
bisschen ich habe schon angst dass die
ganzen komiker kann aber ich jetzt hier
auseinander nehmen aber würde ich hab
diese fayed gekauft okay wir machen
weiter mit dem nächsten schuh letzter
dann habe ich diesen valencia bestellt
der leider noch nicht da ist er ja das
ist echt sehr sehr schade also sieht
wirklich nichts aus ich habe den farbig
bestellt da hätte ich mich so darauf
gefreut aber den werde ich euch
demnächst auf jeden fall auch noch
zeigen als nächstes kommen wir dann auch
hin zu diesem schuh valencia und die
haben mich sogar 106 euro also trat ich
bin mal gespannt ob der balenciaga
draufsteht ich denke eigentlich dass
dürfte irgendwie anders heißen also ich
glaube nicht dass es möglich ist keine
ahnung sieht auf jeden fall qualitativ
sehr sehr meist aus ich hoffe da werde
ich auch positiv überrascht sein wenn
ich den gleich auspacke also leute die
hab ich für nicht bestellt hier haben
war gut da muss ich ganz klar sagen die
gehört nicht zu den teuersten kicker der
welt das sind nicht so einzelstücke die
man für 40.000 dollar verkauft die
kosten im original glaubens 600 euro
ich habe auch noch einen anderen ball
ins lager bestellt der ist leider noch
nicht da vereinigung steht ihr einfach
drauf ich glaube auf dem boden stand
eigentlich über palins jager ich wusste
aber dass es immer auf den schuhen
natürlich nicht funktioniert sollte auf
dem stuhl steht bei julia 2 gewann liang
gab willst du damit raus geht mit den
original schon aber nicht mit baldigen
die young ja also ich finde diesen aus
aber ich mache hier mit einem beweisen
allerdings schreibe ich dir bei den
servern
sie hat ein problem hat dann zieht
jedoch mal an also da muss ich sagen
gefällt mit der er john fluge meint der
jahr 50
das ist ein gutes dingen das
teambuilding bei julia gaß sind halt
jetzt nicht so das gelbe vom ei nen dann
muss man sagen aber wir schauen uns mal
an wie das mit deinem outfit aus
deswegen dass wir uns hier mal nicht
lohnten zieht jedoch einmal an
schuhgröße 40 extra fällig werde die die
schuld in die schuhe
also wenn du mit den original kaufen
willst aber schon bald abgebaut
man kann ihre vereinsfarben kommt muss
man testen ob das der fuß wird wie oa
also ich sag mal so und rast vorne
wirklich dafür
du wolltest ein bisschen mehr platz mehr
wir sind ja ein bisschen zu klein
[Musik]
das trage ich meine neuen bayern machen
heißt der flex alles ich sagen die
kölner auf jeden fall mit meinen toren
flugs hier überhaupt nicht mithalten
das ist ja an sich wenn man jetzt die
modelle in original betrachtet die viel
schöner finde als die das leiden das ist
schon sonderschulen das schon eine
schöne schule einmal die kosten habe ich
so 600 600 und die 20.000 ich muss auch
sagen das finde ich ist ein echt schöner
schule würde ich mir das niemals holen
weil es viel zu teuer ist aber haben
sich kann man das schon feiern schreibt
gern mal die kommentare welches euer
favorit und sollte wenn er den kanal
nicht abonniert haben dann einmal
abonnieren bitte und natürlich den namen
nach oben geben
empfängerin dann kommen wir jetzt zu
einem exemplar das ist der mac das ist
ein schuh der rund 14.000 dollar
verkauft wenn ich euch hier auch mal
gerne ein und da habe ich eben schon
lange zeit den habe ich so weit ich weiß
für 79 euro geschossen das ist der nike
air mac ich glaube so nennt man den ich
glaube das original schließt sich so
automatisch mit der leuchtet ja auch um
die 14.000 dollar wird er gehandelt also
wirklich ein naja ein hingucker weiß
nicht ob ich denn so also da bin ich auf
jeden fall am meisten gespannt ich habe
den ganzen tag hier in diesem grau
bestellt die nike max sind ein replica
der schuhe der figur marty mcfly aus dem
film zurück in die zukunft zwei 37.500
dollar
was ich letztlich für den tick tock
gesehen habe das ist eigentlich echt
lustig gerade das muss ich sagen in
welche situation da sagt also sonst und
dann sagt irgendwie so woher kommt
eigentlich das papier nach also hier
dienst wo man so braucht dann sagt
jemand aus china und dann sagen wenn man
es drückt hat man dann chinesische luft
hier
dazu kommt der verkauf china stimmt kann
die luft kommt direkt aus schön sind
[Gelächter]
also bin ich jetzt endlich mal gespannt
dieser schuh deshalb absolut monströs
das war auch der teuerste der hat mich
irgendwie 79 euro gekostet als fake muss
man sich mal auf der zunge zergehen
lassen und diese balance jahre jünger
waren sogar teurer als der hier
ich glaube die potenziale die genau weiß
ich es nicht mehr ich hab's euch ja
gezeigt das ist doch mal ein schönes
exemplar fast noch auf ihr gehalt bist
du doch der absolute maß mit auf
ladekabel sind die die sich automatisch
zu schließen
das sind die die schlacht zwischen jaja
die also die gehen so automatisch zu und
das ist die kamera aufladen die zieht
sich eigentlich so ein bei den
originalen gelaufen aber ich habe ja
nicht die original jetzt noch eine
betriebsanleitung dabei oder nie sind
die sich zusammenziehen ich weiß es
nicht leisten kann man kann das gar
nicht lesen
was ist das denn alter hier kann man es
leicht das waschbecken und wurde hier
also irgendwie sahen die auch schon
fotos besser aussehen
also ich finde ich auch einen originalen
ultra grip wir haben jetzt in meinen 357
das usb-kabel alltag sogar mit sowas ist
doch mal revolutionär
warum ist nicht jedes kabel so ok dann
laden wir jetzt mal auch dazu zwei
airports gleichzeitig
schon zwei gedrückt
er ist an der leuchte sogar immer hier
und mit leuchteffekt 1 kug der leuchtet
einer blinkt ja ja wir brauchen die
eigentlich gar nicht laden aber das ist
schon eine coole sache muss ich sagen
dass das dass man die zusammen laden
kann
ich musste jetzt erst mal angeboten im
alter länger wenn ich da nicht raus
gehen
da nimmt mich auf jeden fall jeder ernst
ok dann ziehe ich mal kurz meine 40.000
fans aus ich frage mich wirklich werde
wer bestellt ich denn sowas teil und
mainz ernst aber es gibt welche die
gehen automatisch ziemlich ja ich glaube
das sind die die automatisch zogen aber
die 90 euro variante kann das mit ich
dachte erst wegen dem aufladen habe die
frist jetzt so richtig sie sich
automatisch zwischen dumme gans mir
helfen
das muss so locker lässig werden die
gerade machst du den anderen auf mama
kannst du es zu machen bitte mama ich
kam hinten nicht reichen
leute die leuchte aus was soll das denn
jetzt acht leuten doch beide teile ich
will jetzt überhaupt nicht angeben oder
so aber meist nur leuchten und sind
14.000 dollar teuren er sich dem was
sagen die kleinen kinder schuhe von
diesen elefanten von dieser elefant
markt nicht nach scheiße java-basierte
wolle ist ja gefahr was ich euch hier
bei eben einmal mehr ist leider mal
nicht da das ist ein geholter keine
ahnung wie heißt unsere bunte support
sagen
die kommen auf jeden fall noch zeige ich
euch noch instagram alex wie folgt mir
da unbedingt wir dürfen uns aber wieder
marie dann wenn ich euch auch die 1
danke fürs zuschauen und wir sehen uns
bald wieder gibt's neues video jeweils
montags mittwochs und freitags überhaupt
haben an dem text auch mein 2 kanal ab
alex petritsch alex wie und abonniert
aber erstmal wie also leute das land